even opened up his search for
information to answer whatever question
he and dressing and strike in research
methods and done button to employ a good
plethora of different methods across his
conversion study so salty method
research has baby by now within and warm
with a comparative politics but if it
was the case it is certainly up dude at
least with large part 2david work um so
if you kids at my graphic work among the
giro bed his work buddies Survey
Research and for memorials magic Cornish
are well known I actually wanted to
emphasize an Avox first book online
slowly okay save you a little bit less
well than most of the scientists and
especially given to the rise of lather
the field work recently Jimmy is sort of
i think the first work so as the exact
date occasion project and he was working
on to somalia small language and she had
the FG idea that sort of the social
dynamics of conversation de verdad amor
conversing in English or in monee and he
developed a really yeah creative set of
role-playing exercises listening tests
competition in order to test how the
language people were operating in
affected their deference and interacting
with one another how they perceive one
another really on in the can of recent
work have you already bought adults
real innovator and father that one piece
as well so at the type of point I wanted
to make them is substantive so I think
across a lot of different words from
Africa it's to show us that identities
are both very contextual but even though
ya jus good contacts and um is
definitely constructed it's by no means
happy phenomenal right it has really
important side effects on how we
interact with other number theory our
well-being and so we've seen this
compass research on language as a
coordination game in Ghana we've seen
this from his research on when religion
versus village identities and salient
Nigeria and research on Somalia I can
talk to about to lose in this vein as
well so the your contribution and one
thing we can learn from David is I be
not sure if it's exactly the right word
but almost political and this is david
some great determination to find the
truth uh no matter how uncomfortable it
might be like it against all odds and so
me back to his project in somalia you
know he forgot to do this research and
he arrived after two weeks in somalia
about you think instead of giving up on
the project utah there are some always
living in north eastern kenya new
website there you know this
determination and to follow through on
research even under very difficult
circumstances I think his current
research or his most recent research in
France which is also about a current
sentence but it is looking at the
crunchies attitudes towards North
African immigrants has my two answers
that I think are uncomfortable for many
French in that they show higher levels
of discrimination
soon and David sort of dogged pursuit of
the truth even people uncomfortable
debate all of us so with that said the
rest of the time Pete no that's good
enough relay well some of you may be
thinking about the Iran preliminary
agreement my sleep last night was lost
because of Garissa and the tragedy and
massacre in Garissa and it recalls a
story that when I was persona non grata
in in Somalia I was trying to go to the
convention in the Somali studies
international association in Mogadishu
but I couldn't get a visa so i went i
was living then in alief a and i went to
the somali embassy in in lagos to see if
i could appeal and the brother of the
then dictator mohamed siad barre a was
in the federal palace hotel and that
they directed me up to his room on the
top floor spending his country's money
in the federal palace hotel and looking
down on yaba we saw a typical nigerian
scene of of you could call it gang
violence in the middle of the market and
watching people with machetes and clubs
going after each other and the dictators
brother said to me David we may be poor
in Somalia but will never fall to that
and it's a bad prediction but I've long
remembered that because somalia has
become a nightmare for entire generation
and part of the motivation or great part
of the motivation of all these lectures
is to say how come
and why anyway Africa the last frontier
the first lecture was the unfulfilled
dreams of african independence where
those of you are here know that i just
gave a bunch of graphs showing how
africa fell behind on three on three
dependent variables that were three
outcomes that is on economic development
health on a social order and on
democracy and this lecture is more you
could say describing the symptoms the
half-century of dysfunctional politics
describing the symptoms of this failure
and the third lecture will be a search
for causes so here we're more or less
looking at at more descriptive material
trying not to make any great causal
claims a half-century of dysfunctional
politics I took this cartoon from 1999
and Nigeria because we basically told
political scientists that asking whether
we're asking if the regime was
democratic regime was a military rule or
democratic rule led to the same outcomes
and if you were to if you were to say
what's the return to democracy the
answer will be theft and what's the
return to military rule the answer is
theft so what's this right-hand side
variable that you guys are so enamored
with called regime type so in a sense
this motivates this motivates this
lecture is whether the symptoms of this
dysfunction I'm going to take three
different symptoms the first is the
failed cultural project the failed
cultural project the second is the
breakdown of order and the third is
corruption I remind you I'm not going to
make any causal claims by the
descriptive claims of the symptoms of
the dysfunctional politics so start off
with the failed call
a project so here I'm not very good at
reading poetry but you'll have to bear
with me there was a notion in the early
independence or late colonial era in in
english-speaking Africa was called the
African personality or something like
this in French Africa it was
french-speaking Africa it was called the
Negritude movement and the negative
movement really was initiated and and
named by Martin martinique poet ma says
our but picked up by the first president
and soon to become first president of of
Senegal Leopold sang gore and when you
read it may say there are the notion of
white is always associated with anger
violence and hatred but but with sang
gore it's much more white associated
with coldness lure is called Paris in
the snow Lord you visited Paris on the
day of your birth because it had become
poultry and bad you purify that with
incorruptible cold the white death the
morning even the factory funnels hoisted
and harmony the white flags peace to all
men of goodwill lord you have offered
the divided world divided europe the
snow of peace and the rebels fired their
1,400 cannons against the mountains of
your peace lord I have accepted your
white cold that burns worse than salt
and now my heat melts like snow in the
Sun and I forget the white hands that
loaded the guns that destroyed the
kingdom's the hands that wit the slaves
and that whipped you the dusty hands
that slapped you the white powdered
hands that's lat me the sure hands that
pushed me into the solitude and hatred
the white hands that felled the high
forest that dominated Africa and then
the final stanza of his poem called New
York has similar themes as that of Paris
New York I say to you New York let black
blood flow into your blood but that that
it may rub the rust from your steel
joints like an oil of life that may give
your bridges the bend the buttocks and
the suppleness of creepers and the ears
above all the ears to God who added the
laugh of a saxophone created the heaven
and the earth in six days and the
seventh day he slept the great sleep of
the Negro this is powerful stuff
especially for for a guy who marries a
Frenchwoman up and and it gave a promise
of what independence would bring a
promise that there was something
something different and something
powerful that would be result from from
independence not only politics but
culture Kwame Nkrumah and Modibo k2 with
their efforts turned gold coast into
Ghana and french west africa in tamale
with the notion that we need to rename
our own places and our own countries
bringing back to the glories of ancient
empires julius nyerere a tied the
tanzania nation to a common indigenous
language in swahili tanzania had no
meaning locally but so I Healy did an
idea that this is a country of Swahili
speakers Joseph Mobutu renames himself
Mobutu Sese Seko and his country no
longer the Congo but say year thomas
sankara was even more inventive in
Burkina Faso formally up revolta and the
politics of names burkina comes from the
mossy language and and faso comes from
the second language of burkina faso gila
and mohamed siad barre a the leader of
somalia and about whom i wrote my first
book decrees a national script for the
somali language the language that
everyone spoke in virtually everyone
spoke in the country but because of
inability to agree upon an orthography
they operated their schools
systems in English in North in Italian
in the south and in Arabic where the
Egyptians hung out so he brought a
unified national language through a
national script these were some ideas
are bringing in the Jannetty to Africa
but um let me go to this slide first but
in actuality in actuality the well let's
go up here yeah we computed algorithm
called the average distance of the
indigenous languages or the languages of
each group in every African country the
average distance from their language the
official language of the state
determined by where the state laws are
written and secondary school education
medium of secondary at school education
and the the way this average distance is
computed is basically we take the
distance between any two languages using
a data set coming from the Summer
Institute of linguistics which gives an
address for every language in the world
and you're able to count how far any
language is from any other language
based upon the the distance in their in
their language trees how many nodes they
should date they have in common before
they split so a country so like in Spain
you have the case where Catalan and
Castilla no separate very far down so I
have a very low distance whereas Spanish
or custody Castilian and Basque
separated the very first stage and have
a very distant language so what you do
is you compute this average distance to
the official language based upon the
proportion of speakers of each condition
of each indigenous language and and and
multiplied by the distance and what you
get is for all countries of the world
Africa having
just by far the greatest the greatest
numbers of a DOL and if you want to look
at it this way the number of countries
at each level of a DOL Africa stands in
the sense culturally coat culturally
disconnected from its own cultural roots
culturally disconnected from its own
roots so whether the implications of
this yet one implication of this is if
you just look at linguistic difference
or lipstick distance and development for
every continent in the world the greater
the distance the lower the GDP per
capita in the 205 if you do it just for
Africa you see you see the same thing of
course it's the North African countries
that are waiting this somewhat up but
you have the countries which are would
give some degree of oficial ax t and get
shared with the European languages in
the sense the curve would look more or
less the same below neither sharp if you
took out the North African countries so
we see some relationship between average
distance to the official language and
economic development that research I
could send you the early draft some
doing this with an economist Rajesh
ramachandran we control for a whole set
of factors and we find them as I'll get
to later the mechanisms by which average
distance in the sense affects the
outcomes is based upon two factors one
the the availability of the language as
you'll see in a bit so people can hear
it spoken outside of the school system
the degree to which you can hear it
spoken out of the school system and
second the difficulty of learning at
based upon the distance of the address
so if we look at data
and here we're looking at the channel we
call exposure or how much you hear of it
this is data from the southern and East
African consortium for monitoring
educational quality it's a it's a
consortium of about thirteen African
states which had been colonized in the
in English and what we do is we have a
from this about 33,000 respondents or
thirty three thousand kids who've taken
tests and we know a ton about them we
know what kind of house they live in
what the income of their parents is
what's what classrooms they were in and
how many cattle their parents own just a
whole range of what we call
socioeconomic status of the students one
question we ask is is English spoken at
home at all and the amazing thing is
that for both essential reading score
and essential math scores that there's
one fifth of a standard deviation it's
20 points of a more or less like an SI t
type of scoring system about one-fifth
of standard deviation improvement if you
if the kids here english outside the
schools outside of their classrooms so
there's a big negative effect of the
lack of exposure to English for
educational attainment of southern and
East African students then the Summer
Institute of linguistics had originally
been I don't know if you know it's
really an interesting background for
this group they were originally Baptist
missionaries who wanted to have a Bible
written in every single language but
they needed to hire linguists to find
out what these languages were and to get
expertise in the languages but then they
become a more internationalist NGO and
got interested in the question of is
there payoffs to reach the hearts and
minds of kids or reaching the edge
to reach a educational achievement of
kids if they have education than their
own language that only the Bible and
what they did is they set up a
randomized experiment in northwestern
cameroon in which a random set of
schools got education in the local
language column and and another set
balance set we can call it we're still
operating in english and then after
three years of this program they gave
tests to the kids and basically these
are the kids this is the the scores of
the kids who are in the control group
the non calm and come and these were the
ones who were educated through the calm
medium and again this is combined in
math and believe it or not and in
english and the kids did better who were
learning through the medium of calm for
both for both english as a subject and
for mathematics and this suggests that
there is a pretty substantial cost for
the what we could call the cultural
imperialism of the european languages as
they work through the educational system
it's just about two years ago was ended
we're trying to extend it to five years
of education now we're trying to get
support so the next part of this
cultural project is to look at the
question is can African states build
national cultures and the example that
comes from the work of Ted Miguel is
obscure healy promotion in East Africa
and he had this ingenious idea after
doing some research in Busia in Kenya on
on levels of ethnic diversity and public
goods production and when he found in
his original research in Busia was that
that the greater degree of diversity
within a town or a school district the
greater degree of diversity the less the
parents
donated to Harambee schools people were
less public spirited and he found that
with a finish project of wells which
required some mechanical some mechanical
works that the likelihood of a well
break down that was not fixed was much
higher the degree to which there was
ethnically virginity so the idea was
ethnic heterogeneity in the local level
produced lower levels of public goods
lower levels of contributions to
education and lower levels of you could
say collective action to go to the
repair areas to get your to get the
parts to fix to fix the wells then he
thought well is it possible because
Tanzania having this nation building
idea through the common Swahili language
would it be different just a few hundred
miles across the border with basically
similar kinds of ethnic diversity some
towns having heterogeneity Jannetty and
some having ethnic homogeneity and
whether you found was that in the Kenya
case as ethnic diversity increased
public goods went down whether it is a
school funding or or whether it is our
desks per pupil for Tanzania the
relationship is not significant but
anything diversity it has a positive
coefficient with public goods which was
quite amazing finding and then he asked
a question well of course Kenya is much
richer so so of course they're going to
do better the average levels of
education in busia in Kenya is seven
point four years in me at two and
Tanzania it's 4.1 years so they have a
much richer educational system in Kenya
but we knew Kenya was richer but
literacy levels of the male population
with at least four years of education
who were able to read the complete
sentence
Busia was 51-percent in me act 2 and
tanzania was seventy-six percent so the
returns to each year of school were much
higher in tanzania than they were in
kenya the return to educational
achievement investment are lower with
higher a DOL average distance of the
official language and yet the reliance
on the colonial languages as media of
instruction in Africa is near universal
coming from work of emily alba
conclusion to this part the failed
cultural project the hopes of Negritude
were undermined by a neo-colonial
reality for returns on human capital and
public goods the neo-colonial reality
was not an unmitigated good the second
outcome the breakdown of order I'm the
deal with both kuz first and then and
then Civil War well Chris this picture
must bring back sad memories with kwame
nkrumah being ousted by military coup in
1966 and as I mentioned in the first
lecture this was a devastating moment
for those of us who saw kwame nkrumah as
the avatar of a new era the new frontier
that I discussed in my first lecture
apra and crew Mulder deluge the cooze
followed and and Africa you could say
the so-called Westminster transfer
system of the British or French
organized constitutions became became a
history
so the the case of Nigeria just to give
you a sense of what this looked like
there was in the mid-1960s in the
western region of the Yerba speaking
region there was kind of a battle
between a king doula and a wooly whoa
for power there was some degree of
violence and sure enough in january of
1966 the military comes in with a coup
and that general iran see coming from
the east was not supposed to be the
winner of this the military was mostly
led by guys from kaduna over here and
and anyway ballet what the Prime
Minister was killed in this and and and
Iran's he becomes powerful the leader
and he in the eastern region then does
something remarkable he said we're no
longer going to have a federal system
we're gonna have a unitary system
everyone saw this as a way for the small
group in the southeast to control
everything because it would no longer be
federal this dispersions of of wealth
and six months later a counter-coup from
a guy not quite from the kaduna area
from the Middle Belt but called the
northerner there's a counter-coup and
general go on takes power to make a long
story short that was july of 1966 by the
next year the eastern region is seceding
from the union as the country called
Biafra and a million people are killed
coup attempts in sub-saharan Africa
continue in the 60s 70s 80s 90s and
already continuing in the half decade of
the 2010s but something changes the
nature of the coup changes nature of the
coup if we look at two kuz in Ghana the
first coup leader is is I'm craw who was
a lieutenant Journal lieutenant general
the army command was intact and he
served for three years by 1979 coup
Jerry Rawlings was a fright flight
lieutenant a noncommissioned officer
with no organizational authority from
the army takes over and and in the sense
is not it's not the leader of an army
that is running the country but he's a
personal asst ruler who relies on his
one parent of a one-parent ebay ties the
east and that happened to be married to
an akan in in the west and has to pay
off all sorts of other groups because he
has no military organization behind him
he becomes a personal asst leader rather
than a military leader and if we look at
what happens in africa is that the this
is coding from Barbara Geddes the actual
true military rules that is rulers that
is actually running through a military
operation our very military organization
are negligible what you get is
increasing number of personal asst
rulers in in africa and these
personality personal rule is largely
non-institutionalized and short-lived
and that is to say that Barbara Gaius's
work shows that the most short-lived
regimes are those with personal personal
asst rule and as the excellent
Africanist alex de Waal has shown that
the degree to which your rule is
personalist the higher your political
budget the more you have to pay off
different clients all over the country
to in order not to try to overthrow you
so the in a sense the political budget
as opposed to the development budget is
greater extent to which rulers
personalist and so you can say the
pattern the military budget is high in
both cases good question the pattern is
that military coup is by officers then
you get democratic transitions the
democratic transitions breakdown and
military kuz by NCOs and the
implications of this kind of pattern of
cuckoo in one era to coup in the next
era is that coos that go awry trigger
civil wars personalist rule raises the
political budget and here is just a on
making but don't have data to support
regime instability lowers investor
confidence so it's linked personal asst
rule 22 the reluctance of people to
invest in political environments that
they can predict second Civil War I've
already given you some on Nigeria this
is from work in a nice book on on civil
wars by will Reno will Reno for those of
you who haven't read his work is a
really remarkable figure in African
Studies I consider him of the generation
after the one that Bob Bates and myself
come from in that he said as I mentioned
in the last lecture you guys like me or
Bates are looking at national capitals
as if they're important but but what's
really important to these local networks
of shadow state's existing in the
interspecies of of of African societies
and if you're looking at the wrong
places for where authority is really
being exerted and he's been a remarkable
guy in being able to go by backpack
where where no one with children would
want to go and actually figuring out how
these shadow states actually work and he
points out in this more you can called
synthetic book that is a progression of
civil wars in Africa which sort of
resembles that progression of Coos that
I've been talking about in the last sets
of slides first you have the ones of
anti-colonial struggle in Rhodesia there
may be in South Africa and in Angola and
Mozambique against the Portuguese and
people who in the sense started studying
civil wars and violence in that era
tended to be ones that favored
insurgents and saw the insurgents side
of the the issue and then you've got the
challengers to the new states that is
the Xianbei rebellion in contango
supported by some Belgian industrialists
and then nigeria and Biafra and you
start getting a more worried of are you
are you supporting these insurgents how
to think about these insurgents and and
what's the return for these separatist
movements but then you get a set of he
calls them reform rebels and for second
liberation in Uganda it was mu 70
against the second of OT period in
Ethiopia it was MELAS versus the Marxist
mcneese Lou in Rwanda I you could say
God makes RPF against happy hermana and
Somalia I don't know why I would put
that he put it there the somali national
movement against siad barre a so these
were in a sense reform rebels saying the
corruption was just unimaginable of the
regime's the the torture and the
imprisonment were unbearable that this
has to stop and these were insurgencies
that began in rural areas to try to
reclaim the state for the original
principles however you start getting
staked destroying civil wars
whether it be the post-election riots in
Kenya which almost reached which almost
reached Civil War proportions and then
the movement of the emancipation of the
Niger Delta where you begin to see this
not as well some people may still see it
as a goni liberation as Sarah we were
wanted to portray it but began to see it
as extortion of gel and it's somewhere
in between she'll extortion and agony
liberation so on this at this level you
begin to start saying these rebels are
looking at these rebels are doing stuff
for for personal gain rather than for
making their country a better one and
then you get the warlord rebels whether
it's Liberia and Prince Johnson and
Charles Taylor whether it's Foday Sankoh
in and Sierra Leone whether it's gbagbo
in cote divoire or its Mohamed Farrah
Aidid in Somalia I have to take a short
break here with Somalia the the movement
against siad barre a which really begins
after the failure of the ogaden war in
1978 begins three insurgencies to
overthrow siad barre a one coming from
here basically sock based one coming
from here basically major Cain based and
one coming from here basically
hawaii-based and because the Huey days
were closest there UPC army came to
Mogadishu first and because the Italians
were there who liked these guys they
consecrated I think that's a good word
Ally hurts their their president ali
mahady and now he was present but his
principal general was down here Mohamed
Farrah Aidid
and he was angry he thought he should
become the president and most of the
violence of the Somali civil wars is not
you could call major clan against major
clan it's intra Hawaii that started off
as a battle for who should become the
leader of Somalia from this the same
army the UPC army and in the sense you
couldn't see this is a battle for the
liberation of Somalia for some idea you
could just see these guys killing each
other and killing civilians and many
rather large numbers and and you might
say undermining the entire Somali state
for personal gain so talked about the
cultural project and you could say it's
undermining the social order that was
transferred at time of Independence
breaking down in coos and then in civil
wars and civil wars getting from ones
which had purpose to ones which had
almost no purpose other than personal
gain and now the third symptom
corruption and prebend ilysm prebend
ilysm as a word coming from max vapor
suggesting that all offices all offices
are for sale and people own offices
rather than in a sense of work in them
so the four pillars of this prebend
ilysm a corruption clientelism electoral
fraud and non accountability so I start
with corruption so we have this thing
called the transparency index of
transparency of international ranking
and the source is in the quality of
government but basically what we see
here is as you have the least corrupt to
the most corrupt basically
this is average for all countries in
each of these regions the average reach
of these countries regions for each of
these years and we see that Africa is an
outlier again on corruption yes Finn
Finland brings it way up there good
question but they what they don't
measure the actual corruption they what
they do is they do surveys of business
people there and say how many days does
it get to how many days is it take to
get a permit how much you have to pay to
get something to a poor so it's it's a
survey of business leaders and many of
the business leaders in the Africa day
that are Europeans being asked about
doing business there so they as long as
it's anonymous they have every reason to
be honest but there's been a whole lot
of back and forth on what they're really
measuring sometimes when I look at
transparency indices I think that people
are rarely asking what I want my
daughter to be an intern in that country
and how nice is the place for for my
family because I don't think they're
actually computing how much they're
actually how much they're actually
bribing but nonetheless what you get
across countries in Africa is consist
consistent results over time which
suggests it's measuring something and
certainly measuring something which
which has for long been until recently a
reluctance for international
corporations to invest to invest
directly now what about
kind of ethnic corruption or clientelism
this is an interesting question one of
my former students who is now a
professor at Columbia King muli kisara
wrote the paper which had a shocking
result what she looked at is all the
marketing boards in Africa or a large
number of states of Africa she look at
the marketing boards marketing boards
are essentially monopsonist buyers of
agricultural products and they can in
the sense lower the the price paid to
the farmers and that could and
difference between the price that can
sell that and the price they buy that
becomes rents for the state or quote we
can call attacks and she asked the
question which products get taxed the
most and she got data on the ethnicity
of every single president and the major
crop of that presidents area of birth
and asked whether in fact the farmers
got much closer to the world market
price if they were of the same product
ethnic group of of the leader and the
results were astonishing she found that
people who were the same ethnic group of
the leader with attacks the highest and
no one could interpret those results but
it led to a whole range of research in
Africa trying to get this trying to see
how general her findings were and then
you had Eric Ramon and Dan Posner do a
study in six states on 44 different
outcomes education water electricity and
inference survival and asked to the
extent to which being the and it's done
each year so you would know the the
ethnicity of the leader and the region
of the leader and what you can see here
if it goes to the right of zero it means
that the if
if so happens a Callaghan is president
this can be more education than would be
predicted by population going to Cal
engines but no effect on potable water
and what you see here is a bunch of
uninterpretable results that that in
some cases in some countries you get you
get a leadership advantage so in Senegal
with with non mole of leaders with low
loves getting much higher education
levels that you find a negative
relationship changes every three years
thank you next slide so this is the now
the sort of the gold standard of the co
ethnic leader and with a whole number of
lags put in of the kind you're asking
for but the co ethnic leader predicts
averaging over all of Africa some
primary education completed primary
education and infant death and infant
death is in a sense changes from year to
year in the allocation from the Ministry
of Health for health clinics so in a
sense we're seeing that clientelism
plays a crucial role in in outcomes that
we care about even if kammula kisara
showed that the tax issues were
surprising a surprising result in
another direction so this seems to be
four key public goods and allocations a
big effect of being of the same ethnic
group of the leader
work of laura's Eric see Thurman shows
if you look at what they do what see
Thurman and his team has done is looked
at every single cabinet in every year in
all African states or actually all
states in the world and and asked the
question if you were an included group
in the in the cabinet your junior a
senior partner or a junior partner an
excluded group a powerless group or
discriminated group how many years did
you have of ethnic conflict with the
state and what percentage of of years
and what they find is that excluded
groups have much higher probability of
being in civil war with the state and
what they also show is that if you've
moved from a junior partner to excluded
that's a trigger people like fear and
myself argue against these guys and say
what explain why they were demoted it
may be expectation that they were going
to be at war but nonetheless there's a
beginning of a relationship of
consolidated ethnic leadership in
African states and paying paying a cost
for that paying a cost for that and I'll
explain that in my next lecture and when
I try to give a causal interpretation of
this pay a cost for excluding groups so
ethnic clientelism not only has public
health implications but has implications
for violence so this is again if you
look at included groups versus excluded
groups and the probability of ethnic
conflict on set this again comes from
see them in oil what you see is even
controlling for GDP per cat that the
that excluded groups are more likely to
be in ethnic in violence against the
state
so we now go from clientelism from from
from transparency corruption forticlient
ilysm and now to electoral fraud that's
not very interpretable but free and fair
elections looking at countries for each
of their elections and what we find is
if if that as we get up here we're
talking about on the whole how would you
rate freeness and fairness of the last
national election free and fair
completely free and fair is for and what
we see is a good number of countries
down at the level of two and three so
this is from the Afro barometer and more
interpretable way to look at this is to
say illicit strategies again coming from
afro barometer looking at fraud and and
violence that is they ask the question
do you have to be careful when you
deliver your public political opinions
is that something or you'll you if
you're not careful you're likely to pay
consequences that's the careful one the
violence is is there violence in your
area between people of different
political parties and then the last one
in vote-buying and what you find is
rather high levels although Ghana has
certainly improved in the past number of
years but rather high levels of expect
of reports of fraud of reports of you
could say political intimidation of
violence and a vote buying
yeah that's why I think Ghana this is
really good I think that's right so the
the last set is really remarkable
research of mccarton Humphries and the
Jeremy Weinstein and what they did in
Uganda asking the question what is the
degree of political accountability in a
legislative system and what they did is
they created a report card for every
single member of the National Assembly
every single member and with all this
information of their district their
status what portfolios what committees
and then they gave grades for committee
assignment constituency services and
whether they attended degree to which
they attended the plenary sessions and
the degree to which they attended their
own committees and this score was
elaborately elaborately created and
tested for accuracy and then what they
did is they randomly randomly chose
districts in which in which this people
would be brought into it was it was all
published nationally every single report
card was published in Kampala of
nationally but then there were random
rollouts to places where local people
would be shown the report card and they
would be discussing in kind of focus
groups and what did they find they found
that for constituency that's looking at
one of the measures the degree to which
they did consider the constituency work
and rank from 0 to 100 from bad to good
and the share of re-election and we see
what we should expect the better the
constituency service the medic
constituent service the more likely be
elected that's not so bad but what they
did is a very very clever regression
discontinuity test they took these were
all grades if you got here you got an A
if you got here you got to be if you got
here you got an F so what they did is
they took those closest to the ones who
just barely got bees vs. the ones that
barely got a's and said let's look at
the places where we rolled this out did
the one who got the higher grade even
though there was no difference really in
degree of constituency service did they
get any extra vote getting returns the
answer was zero and that great study yes
they're playing attention of services
and and that's the and that's the
objective measures that's not the way
they interpret it they interpreted as a
as that that the higher performance MPs
were more likely to be reelected but
receiving a higher grade does not appear
to affect the likelihood of being
reelected I'll tell them I'm going to
see McCartin tomorrow tell them that you
like you think it's a good thing so let
me summarize this lecture the dreams of
the cultural project from Negritude to
african personality were quietly
abandoned at considerable cost although
there were some as i said symbolic moves
in Burkina Faso or or in or in calling
yourself sis a sec oh the charismatic
founders gave way to self and grand
Iseman economic catastrophe military
rule and personal istic dictatorships
running what will reno calls shadow
states that is
if you wanted to get order you weren't
going to get order from the political
capital you're going to get order from a
local coalition of chiefs and and others
and merchants and and that was going to
supply the order the pre bendel state
and Richard Joseph's language shadow
state in Reno's and for Alex the wall
it's the high political budget that
these personal istic rulers had to pay
in order to remain in power violence
degenerated from broad dreams of freedom
to nightmares of distributing this
political budget and the corruption and
lack of accountability of African
leaders prevented economic initiative
and the provision of public goods these
are the symptoms the big question is
whether the causes of the failure of the
dreams of independence I haven't really
as I mentioned earlier haven't really
tried to say what was causal that let
that leads Africa's lag or the explains
Africa's lag versus other
post-independence countries in other
words why has Africa not cross the
frontier of providing a life of security
health and opportunity to its citizens
we now through a generation now of
research have begun to get some answers
to the question but the answers are
rather dispersed and they form the basis
of a final lecture let me just give you
a quick overview of what this final
lecture will be on monday the search
again is for causes to account for why
Africa is the last frontier to assure
its populations you can have a growth
health social order and democratic rule
in establishing cause now I'm going to
get a little high-techy or maybe too
techy that is not only demonstrating an
association because you have no idea
what the direction the causal arrows go
or whether in fact it's what we often
call an omitted variable x a' something
that we think is causal is really being
caused by something else and therefore
social scientists say we need to
establish exogeneity the putative cause
cannot be influenced by the outcomes to
be explained so we need to to show that
the putative cause was as if randomly
assigned to some observations but not to
others that's the gold standard of
causal analysis in social science
successful demonstration of Exile
Jannetty is said to solve the
identification of cause problem and so
what I have done and will discuss in the
final lecture eight treatments that
plausibly meet the as if random
criterion of causation and just as a
kind of view of what these eight causal
accounts will look like when I've
already discussed in QA of the first
lecture the geography and demography of
Africa and the demographic challenge
that African states have faced and
colonial states in Africa have faced the
same from the work of Jeffrey curbs
second some innovative and an exciting
research coming out from Nathan none on
the effects of the slave trade and the
Africa has suffered from the slave trade
to extent that no other continent no
other population has in modern times and
the can we actually assess the degree to
which the slave trade has an effect on
outcomes that we care about and the
astonishing results coming from from
Nathan none is that we can identify
these causal effects the third is the
partition of africa the berlin
conference of 1884 and 1885 does the
creation of borders and boundaries as
was done artificially by a bunch of
diplomats who had never actually set
foot in africa have an implication for
africa's for why africa is the last
frontier why Africa is more violent less
able leadership less able to project
power then we move
the partition to the role of the
missionaries and I'm going to provide
based on some recent research and anti a
chi bay view of the role of of
missionaries that they that the
conclusion imma come to is not that
Africa was screwed by the Protestants
but in fact they didn't get enough
Protestants then I'm going to look at
the colonial state and to ask is the
type of colonial state the way the
colonial state was organized does that
have a role in Africa which
distinguishes it from the rest of the
world I'm going to look independently of
cultural diversity the e.l.f the ethnic
ethno-linguistic fractionalization and
see if we can trace the effects of
cultural diversity on lower levels of
public goods and lower levels of Human
Services seventh I'm going to look
something that status raised in the last
lecture the international support of
what's called cured juridical states
that is the fact that boundaries have
become in the sense as Julius nari once
said that the boundaries are so absurd
in Africa we must consider them
sacrosanct and and does that Sankar
sacrosanct aspect of African boilers
have held it back from from giving
leadership to those who can best project
power and the last 10 look at was the
prevailing economic doctrines at the
time of Independence and the role that
the eklai and economists like Raul
Pradesh brought to Africa as what would
get them rapid rapid economic
development so i'll be looking at those
accounts giving some assessment of them
in the final lecture but that's all for
today
would you go to the previous slide what
you call the of the next one ya know the
previous one so you have here for
accounts which you've gained our
symptoms and not causes and I'm
wondering whether you call them sink of
them of course it's not because they're
don't have any cause I think I've back
because it's difficult to demonstrate or
they haven't been applied in a random
way and so I would like you to start
from you know each one and reflect on
their potential those are effective is
not a SUV are not going to treat them as
cause a potential quarters in your last
lecture I'm going to build allege the
causal accounts so the question let's
take a let's take the case of of a DOL
where it wasn't official languages
weren't randomly imposed on States in
fact in fact it was completely obvious
to anyone watching the African scene in
the late nineteen fifteen 50s early
1960s a a quote from Ali mazui at that
point was that that choosing any
indigenous language in most African
states would have would have so angered
every other group that the only thing
that was fair was to choose a language
no one spoke Ali's particular nice way
of saying things so in a sense you in a
sense the choice to say the choice of
English in Ghana was a choice it's not
quite right well what explain
that choice we find two factors that
that explain it one is that every time
is another ethnic group or linguistic
group that adds to the mixture of
relevant actors would make I'm going to
say this as best I can't would make the
condition of a lottery that is would you
join a lottery to choose the official
language from all the languages in the
state and we can show formerly the more
groups there are the less willing any
group would be willing to join the
lottery so in a sense that that the
choice becomes harder the more groups so
e.l.f in the sense makes the collective
decision of choice for one of one of the
languages more difficult second we find
that the and this was in a rather
amazing finding but from Jared Diamond
we we looked at the three places where
writing was first invented and we put
into the distance of each country's
capital to to the closest place where
writing was originally invented and we
found that in the sense combining those
two predicts eighty percent of the
variation in a DOL so in the sense it
was distance from the invention of
language sorry invention of written
language and the large numbers of ethnic
groups which is basically explained by
latitude that explains the eight
explains the egg DOL what I've done
today has shown the effect of a DOL on
educational outcomes or you could say
the association of a DOL with outcomes
rather than giving it a causal account
so it's going to play a role in the last
one but I'm unwilling to say that that
language choice was in the sense
exogenous or as if randomly
that's the best I can do I can imagine
the lectures you could have given this
lecture yesterday and this is the failed
project cultural so you could have
inverted the two lectures and like the
gdp per capita as i could be the
symptoms so again i get the answer you
gave to stop this but saying i wonder
whether that ranking that ordering of it
setting up which causal channel I worry
about this a lot and and I don't I don't
have the vocabulary to explain what this
lecture is doing different from the
first lecture except for the first
lecture I gave you some basic regression
regression models and you know Darwin
acemoglu Drusus is the first ten pages
of his micro economics textbook just to
give you a very stark picture of the
situation and here I tried to give it
just a little bit more flesh but you're
right tatianna if I had done it the
other way around I could call the I
could call the the one I gave first the
symptoms of or the manifestations of the
ones I talked about today so i don't
really i haven't seen this organization
and when i first started this project
which came in undergraduate course i was
going to start off with a third lecture
the causes and then get to the effects
which was the first lecture but
rhetorically not scientifically but
rhetorically it didn't make any sense to
me you had to have to motivate the
project by the outcomes but so yeah
still on satin basically
so your last slide is is essentially
eight experiments that you think can
shed light on some of the causal
relationships that you that you're after
and that the concern I have is that that
gives you the possibility in
theoretically of finding eight
mechanisms when we know in fact there's
an infinite array of causal links these
are for the really important ones but
they're there there's an infinite number
and and so they'll live it's just that
the the fundamental method has these
limits that you you don't have enough
power even have enough enough experience
you don't have enough degrees of freedom
to be able to tease out the delicate
mechanisms all we're going to be able to
see of these the the crudest of
mechanisms and then to fill in the
intermediate steps I'm not sure what the
right method is to think about but I'm
pretty sure it can't be the tools we
have at our disposal because those tools
aren't subtle enough to be able to
disentangle the the causal chain leading
from the distance from the official
language out to these final outcomes you
might be able to say that there's a
causal relationship but but the richness
is being able to trace out the path
through through violence degenerating
corruption and our tools are right well
I agree with that ninety percent but you
having set a standard here of actually
I've actually hanging out with women
farmers that we have people in
economists of your sort but also
anthropologists who have actually hung
out and watched and have a sense when
you read their work of what they see is
the causal mechanisms so it's not we
haven't gotten these eight things from
God we've gotten them from people who
like me been a Peace Corps or you
being you know sort of an adventurer oh
wow are you a peace corps to UM and you
can always be square the great effect on
American social science I'd look no
effect I can detect in Africa but so and
so that those of us who watched going
back to the a DOL those of us who have
watched English being or schools being
taught in in rural Africa and seeing
that the teachers don't speak the
language in which in which the
information is being imparted would have
come up with this abstract term the
exposure channel now it's true we all
know who hung out in these areas the
teachers who can't speak very well
immediately go into the local language
if they can in order to explain what
they just tried to say in French or
English but then that then they're
taking these exams in English or French
and it's it's a disaster now I didn't
tell you when looking at the sack mac
data that that only about five percent
of the students have reached the minimum
standards expected so even though
there's a even though there's a return
for having them spoken at home it's
still a disastrous outcome so the small
area where I disagree is that I think
these these causal mechanisms are subset
of the Infinity that people who have
actually smelled walked and incorrectly
bought onions have observed that's the
question on similar line that one
approach would be to look at one causal
chain very carefully all the way through
another approach would be to look at in
variables that are actually just not
quite as far away from the pen of arable
so they are endogenous in a sense but
they still give us some explanation what
I had in mind was some of you hadn't
really talked about much which is the
kind of organization of the economy and
in particular the kinds of groups that
are in business or labor that are
usually what we look to in for example
us to explain political outcomes but
don't really play a big role here
certainly in south africa i play a big
role also the organization of the
political parties themselves i was
wondering if that's going to enter your
account or if you can just comment on
that if you have data on those kinds of
variables that would apply to a
cross-national study it'd be great if I
could but I actually don't I should look
into this more but the this is closer to
what I think will Reno should have done
if he were just a bit closer to the to
the to a kind of a positivistic frame
and to say here the three or four
different kinds of shadow organizations
and and some of them have a clan or a
tribal basis some have connections as I
mentioned the other day to Lebanese
businessman some are rooted in
protection of mines and some are rooted
in protection of agricultural sort of
communities whether can we get a
typology of these different shadow
states and then say whether whether the
returns to the different kinds of
coalition's and I've pushed my own
students to develop Reno's work in that
way and haven't haven't gotten the
dissertation out of it yet but but I
think that that's an area of tremendous
promise and I wish it was coming from
Northwestern but someone else is going
to have to do it but I don't know any
literature I don't know if Chris does
but I don't know of any literature that
actually has a good a good kind of
typology of these different shadows
state so people like Jim Ferguson and
others will point out these networks
but but in the sense calls them all the
same thing but they're very different in
different situations with probably
different implications and I don't know
what they are Matt first part of the
lecture depend a lot on the national
level of comparisons I understand from
first lecture that very much the same
thing so I was wondering if you've ever
considered looking at sub-national
comparisons but in a particular way so
comparing regions in Africa to regions
in other parts of the world that were
say similarly underdeveloped in leggings
say it's like Papua New Guinea Borneo or
parts of Amazonia or something like that
and if you did to be paraffins the same
way would you find really dramatic
differences between those areas parts of
sub-saharan Africa that were let's say a
similar level of economic political
development 1900 and if you found it
there there are similarities in their
trajectories or say they're starting
points in our ending points in two
thousand might that suggest that well
this really meant something special
about Africa it's not something special
about like Zeta particular
long history or the kind of specifically
African story that you're telling ya so
before I answer directly there have been
a good number of studies looking at the
same ethnic group across across a border
stelios megalopolis and elias popping
out I've have done this a nice paper by
by alex lee and ken schultz i'm on the
cameroon nigeria border so you look at
the same group with slightly different
institutional factors and getting some
some return on that but the closest
thing that's been done that i know of
more directly to your question is a
research i'm now doing with fear on on
Civil War persistence and what we're
finding is something that that speaks to
your issue in the 19th century Latin
America had an incredible number of
civil wars and Africa was basically
experiencing what the what the co w
carol oates of war folk call extra
systemic wars which we ordinary people
call imperialist wars and so imperialist
wars in the 19th century that is if you
looked at the places where they were
actually fought based on today's
boundaries are big predictors not big
but significant predictors of civil war
outcome civil war on sets
post-independence whereas civil civil
wars in in Latin America in the 19th
century are not predictive of wars in
the twentieth and one of the things
we're beginning to infer from that is
that the imperialist wars will call
state destroying
and the civil wars of 19th century 19th
century Latin America were Tilly asked
State Building wars and one inference we
might make from this although we're
worried about it is that the civil wars
were seeing in Africa are comparable to
19th century wars in Latin America and
if you just bring Africa back in time as
it were what you're calling for these
civil wars are examples of early State
Building we're not ready to go public
with this because there are too many
compounds but that's the kind of thing
you're asking for if it is a question of
timing that is what racine Africa is
what happened in other areas of the
world earlier which is the ter its
medieval Europe what we were missing
perhaps is the knowledge of what
happened in Europe which exists in
African how can one day with this kind
of issue the fact that these people we
know what happened the answer is an
adverb poorly but they they doing they
do know this history however I don't
want to push this too far because Latin
America did did not have first of all I
had a settler a settler population and
did not have a majority of the
population that it has accessories I
experienced the slave trade and if we
find independent effects of the slave
trade being rather large you could say
that's unique to Africa and some of
these cases will be unique to Africa
with rather large predicted effects so
although there'll be some relationship
to 19th century that in the sense some
features of Africa one of them being
safe trade another one being Berlin 1884
1885 which differentiate it and for
which we can identify
identify affects him in participate in
the research two things that are sort of
big sergeant to the continent apart I
think it's partly during focusing on the
same with distinguishes Africa from the
rest of the world and what distinguishes
it the content that sort of thing
international phenomenon but in some
ways I think the focus on the
confidential trajectory of the whole it
prevents us from looking at giving
African leaders in African for general a
lot of agency indistinctly us
institutional choices that some PA some
people didn't regarding economic
policies regarding the super full
education policies are not regarding
whether they pursued centralization or
not and some of you think that they have
maybe that's a different project but I
yeah I agree i will be talking about i
will be talking about the few slides
next time on the so-called african wager
which i mentioned last lecture between
hoof way Bonnie and and kwame nkrumah
and the policy choices of trying to
build a socialist state without it
without the state apparatus and the the
great Elliot the correct Elliot Berg
critique of of the socialist experience
and the implications of it but your
overall right and I mentioned this in
the in the first lecture as I looked at
as i looked at the syllabi taught in the
last 15 or 20 years of african politics
which i have not been part of the
perspective you took was the dominant
perspective understand the tremendous
variation within Africa understand that
the agency the crucial aspects of agency
and and the effect you can draw or infer
from this and and you're right I decided
to take a different perspective that if
you looked at the slides from the first
week you would say
there's something more general here can
we account for it but I I understand
it's a different project with very
different implications for how we think
about agency so but maybe it's not
general nothing you said you still
you're still looking for distinctively
African patterns and it seems to me a me
I was wondering here why is it
corruption there is a potential proposal
story well this corruption everywhere so
we're explaining the same for the
African panic on the other hand it may
be that corruption is causally imported
in a different way in a very high
globalized world so you wouldn't
corruption might be having similar
effects in Africa in African countries
as it's been having in Afghanistan and
other Middle Eastern countries in some
of the former Asiatic Republican
southern union that's hugely important
causally in the production of failed
states that say but it's not
distinctively African although it might
be you know mopping up a lot of what
they find yeah so I don't want to say
that corruption is unique to Africa that
would be that would be violating what
every one of us has experienced but we
do see in we do see two things we see in
transparency international that on
average it's a different level and on on
basic interviews we see that
international business well until these
new laws about compliance about
international bribery but you from the
interviews you see that what
international business basically wants
is predict predictable corruption how
much how much does it cost to do this
and can I just can I just pay it upfront
and get the license but
but in in terms of time and change and
who you pay your corrupt bribe to if
that's not predictable then you tend to
give TI folk worst score so I remember a
dissertation being done in Basra during
the during the worst of the 20 5 206
period in in Iraq and the complaint of
most of the merchants was not the
corruption at the at the stopping points
where the blockades but the fact that
they couldn't predict when when it would
occur and how much would be asked and it
made in the sense it made operations of
corrupt business much more much more
difficult so it's the lack of
predictability which seems to be higher
based upon TI data in Africa than
elsewhere I don't want to say corruption
as causal I said corruption was a
symptom of something which i'm going to
try the because the first question you
ask is why is there so much corruption
you're the first question we ask once
you see description is why is there so
much corruption what's what's what's the
source of this why can't they run a
state in which in which exchange is
predictable immediately begs for some
exogenous factor which leads to the high
levels of unpredictability
the multi-faceted where is Africa as a
person so if you're say why is there
violence right then you know corruption
or unpredictability may be part of that
right when you try to kind of both I
think map Africa is a continent but also
to do it in terms of you know what
you're seeing is kind of interrelated
facets of it then it makes it in
politics of the table can we think of
corruption is being causal for various
various elements of it yeah one way I
think about this Ellen is is it one of
the critiques I often get is that
everything is contextual and when by
trying everything is affected by
everything else and I say well context
really the basic meaning of context is a
scheme of interwoven threads and my
research project has always been to see
if I could actually unravel that to
actually see the independent causal
effects of each of these threads even if
I know that once they're all put
together it looks like what most
scholars call context yes so it's not
that it's not too good for taking both
yeah it's part it's part of a causal
chain Steve I want to ask about the coos
of the military so it I mean seems to me
that Africa very weak inheritances of
factors that following on from here were
found in many post colonial countries so
they the military's had officer cores
that had really been digitized only in
the last few years before independence a
very small amount of time so that has an
effect has got to interview to explore
the 60s on organizational hierarchies in
cohesion and also they tended to be
ethnically very unwise emptive at a big
difference in terms of the
for Sakura and the man and that
difference in that dimension further
week of the organizational cohesion and
I bet you if you were trying to explain
these coos in the 60s and 70s a lot but
that difference would be explained by
the interaction between these two
factors i mean the Belgian Congo
mutinies at the point of independence
because you have a completely Belgian
office record you know a local a local
enlisted men and they just launched an
evening against the officers and I bet
you these laser shifts that you see from
officers enlisted are related these same
time factors so again it's not
particularly Africa it's just that you
have this broader factor that is much
worse in the African colonies than it is
in other places well I don't want to I
don't want to make Africa into a
variable i want to say whether the
factors in africa and if it is in a
relationship of officer corps to
enlisted which is let's say more
dispersed in Africa than it's a in India
or or Pakistan or elsewhere up I would
want to be able to code for that or the
kind of thing that you've done of how
many years has there been an officer
corps indigenous officer corps or
something of that sort but one of the
one of the early research projects I did
I think I was a graduate student was I
listened to the famous 1966 tapes of the
in the aburri Ghana of the of the
military leaders of each of the regions
in in Nigeria and the amazing thing
about this this was after the goal
wan-koo when when Ojukwu was trying to
trying to secede and one of the most
interesting they didn't know it but they
were being recorded and all the
transcripts became available as well as
the voices all of them all of them were
Sandhurst graduates
they spoke to each other in English far
better than what you're hearing from me
and and they all use pet names for each
other and they in a sense were
consolidated officer corps with
Sandhurst values and when they came out
ojukwu said in them in the most you
could say Lee and grant way well it
looks like we're going to be at war so
in a sense the military officer corps
had the kind of cohesion that you would
have expected from a real army but yet
but yet something else drove them
something else drove them to war so I'm
worried to say that the that the that
the congolese or congo kinshasa army had
these they're disasters because of a
unintegrated officer corps once the
Belgians left because Nigeria with a
highly integrated one and consolidated
one has a result with with with some of
the same disastrous consequences the
trend towards or the rise impersonalist
regimes for the true slide is that you
need to Africa know or is that how does
that compare to other common question I
have to look at that it's in the
Guinness data set I believe personalist
rule is much more common in Africa by
having actually examined that and the
the cases in the North Africa Middle
East tend to be more hybrid regimes so
Sadat would be called a hybrid regime
and and less personal istic there are
some democratic regimes in Africa that
are trending toward
personal list or we might not realize
there are no longer democracy their
personal list until it's too late is
that yes this is a lecture on Barbara
goddesses coding rules and let's just
say that the organism the organization
of that data set is something I would
like to improve because about thirty
five percent of our cases are called
hybrids which have no theory behind them
at all and I think we need to do better
so I'm not going to defend the coding
sir I'm wondering if you can explain the
situation of Africa without taking
seriously into account international
context because I Africa I mean the
countries are so weak that external
actors are very powerful you know we
don't decide on in the African country
we don't have the ownership of the
politics that they are economically
yesterday you Martian that you know
everything is decided from outside when
this country became independent in 1960s
or the major institution where are you
created well by you I'm f do you n all
these things were already created so we
don't have any control on the rules but
not let us take corruption I
participated in a study of corruption
Gardevoir rather that the most important
part of Prussian was related to foreign
companies who signed contracts or get
acceleration from taxes you know so if
for example where to pay taxes as
national code above example I will have
four more time money than what the
international community key to
so we are merely mini I mean each level
even a different 11 can find such
relations for example mini study has
shown that the goose or dictators cannot
really laugh if they don't have external
support even the language so you can see
for myself when I was in high school are
to study German because Germany founded
I can the ministry of education before I
finish up to study Islamic law hara
because Saudi Arabia provided the money
and things I keep changing so these
people don't have a Knesset the
ownership of what he's done and I'm not
saying that African are not responsible
for that but it works the situation work
because internal actors are confirming
people inside that share very impressed
and in your lecture I don't see that I
think that you you already you
concentrated in Africa I can sorry my
vision feel if you really concentrated
in German factors what it is this is
really meaningful and my last
intervention is that I don't I'm really
not comfortable when I heard people
speaking to God Africa like a kind of
unit of entity is so diverse than Europe
Europe you can speak but in Africa is
very difficult Somalia Kenya or device
it's very difficult so the image that
you your lecture projected I cannot see
it for me it is the kind of fun which is
not really reality you know for you can
find countries that are to justify what
as
what you project it and visit for me
because of the diversity because you saw
desert so that you can find a concrete
and the opposite to say exactly the same
thing so so thank you for that I think
the first parts of your remarks is
something i can say something about and
that is yes i agree and by the way you
generalize that african states are in
general week visa V countries the other
countries in the international the
coulomb the OECD states plus China in
general they're weaker and heavily
influenced by by foreign aid that say as
you say that if you give us a number of
Arabic speakers will give you 200
mosques or something of this sort so sup
subject to tremendous influence by the
outside and basically that's saying
African states in general are pretty
weak visa V the rest of states the world
that could be heavily influenced I'll
have data to show that as I mentioned in
the last lecture that the degree to
which African states are on the Security
Council they're likely to get more
foreign aid in other words this is like
bribes for votes and they're subject to
this these are what you call these weak
African states which are influenced
heavily by outside interests and the
question the research question which
follows from that is why why is it
they're weak in regard to the pressures
coming from the other states in the
world and they're their own choices are
let's say what language to teach their
best students are affected by bribes
coming from the outside and that's the
fundamental challenge that I'm trying to
address although as I can tell from your
remarks not entirely successfully
thank you very very much